the National People's Congress is
China's biggest political event of the
year
drawing almost 3,000 delegates from
across China one of the few occasions
when all of China's leadership is on
show but the government's own advice is
for people to avoid large public
gatherings that means this year's NPC is
almost certain to be postponed
possibly delaying a key announcement on
economic growth targets China's
President Xi Jingping
says that getting the economy moving
again while containing the spread of the
virus remains his priority he has to
tell the Chinese people something you
can choose total blackness or you can
choose a sort of veneer of transparency
what we don't know as we've all
governments is what's happening behind
closed doors all those sorts of things
and more importantly for transparency
what we don't know is that what's coming
out in the media is something and we can
necessarily trust Ryan Manuel is an
expert in China's public health system
he says the government's initial
response to the outbreak in early
January was correct it reacted very
quickly it found out what the virus was
it got a test for the virus and in that
period two weeks afterwards it reacted
appallingly this past week Chinese
diplomats have been on the offensive
defending the expulsion of three foreign
reporters and brushing aside
international skepticism over the
constant changes to China's testing
criteria for the virus but that
criticism has been very selective says
one analyst they shout at the US and
saying that that us making the virus
worse and it's discriminatory against
China
but when nowadays Russia made a decision
to close the border for all the Chinese
nationals they cannot say a word it's
not just the National People's Congress
that's now in doubt so too is a key
economic conference known as the Bao
Economic Forum also held each year in
March if the National People's Congress
is cancelled then analysts say there's
one thing guaranteed to be missing from
the agenda when it does eventually
convene a call to hold China
leaders to account for this crisis
Adrian Brown al-jazeera Hong Kong